TONIGHT.
>>THAT CONFRONTATION SUCTWEEN TA
RUSSIA OVER THE DOWNED AMERICAN
DRONE COME FN UKRAINTHERN  V, IG
PRNENGIN INDUSTRIA
BANOT LETTING OUR FIGHTERSS RESN
>> WL,E TALKING
E ARE THE
DEATH TOLL FOR RINTE
UKRAINE IS UNBELIEVABLE.
AVA DIARTOUSSIAN,
INE AI
ERS UNDERTOOAI
OLMARCH 4TH, O5 SOLDRS
MARCHREMAE
STAGGERINGOS
BE TRUCK MATS,
ANDOC
IT.
TAKE A LAT THIS.
>>HIE FIOT LIKE SOME KIND OF MOE
, 'S OUR REALITY STATEYING TO R.
INJURNORE HROM  FEW MILES OUTS
BAD ERNIGHT HOURS INKRNE,
ROMAN U ED PRETHE CAN LUCKY ENOC
WERE IN
HEN YOU WERE TIH, I SEE L
STUFF.
AND I CAN'T EN
TRIED TO DO
SOCAG OKTHE -- IT'
HELDCAN
YD VIDEOS OF YOURSELF
INREY THFIGHTING IS GOING ON AR
SOT AN SEE SOME OF OUCING. HORR
COMBAT YOU'VENN THDS
OF.
WHAT Y BAK?DERSTAND YOU'RE A SNK
>>YO ABOUT BO THEMS ENI E IN THE
, INU VE
>> YOU SEE- 'S
THAT,-- CAN'T
S
ACAND IF -IF YOU
QUICKLY THAN YOU
SURVIVE, TS  GHTS, HIG ABOUT MY.
FAMILY, NO, ING.
ONLY IF YOU'REH
YOURSELF AND FOLLOWSE AND T D  A
EXPERIENCE YADH WAGHTERS.
>> I'M ON
POSITIONTTG  THIS.
GUN. WCONTUEGHTING FOR FREOM
>> WE HAVE BEEG
ABOUT A LOT OFFO
THATMA HEY'VETORCNDING OUT OF
TION,  HRIENCE BEEN FIGHTING
FORCES? I DON'TO  IT BEST
ANOSITION ANT  DON'T
BEE  TRUE.EBODY TELL ME T NGS WN
THEYN THE  YOUITE IT'S TRU
I T  PEOPLE REAL
RS CAN R WITHOUT AFRAID TOIT LN
SEE HOW THE FELLOWFA CONTINU
M WH  THAT S, ANUCDEYT
RE.AG ONLNLY ON
POSITIONTAKE OUR
TAG  HNO CN TOE POSITION, BECAU.
TONIGHT, I KNOW YOU'RETOK NT
NEE WAMILY.
DO YOU HAVE IDHEN YOU'LLBE ABLEI
E  WILL BESSTHOUT TH
>> WO YOU THT THEM
>> YOU KNOW,THE WAR, IT'S
ONE OFT THIN
ARITTLE BIEME TIRED CH COMPANY E
>> RHEKI OPEOPLE.